[Music]
in just a few days vladimir putin has
not just invaded ukraine
he seemingly threatened nuclear war on
anyone trying to stop him president
putin has ordered russia's strategic
nuclear forces to be placed on high
alert
could putin really start a nuclear war
is putin threatening nuclear force
when vladimir putin announced his
invasion of ukraine early on thursday
morning he warned that nobody should get
in his way or they would suffer grave
consequences and he didn't say what
those were but everyone understood that
it was a reference to nuclear weapons
what he's done over the weekend is make
that threat even more explicit by saying
he's going to move his deterrence forces
which are the way that they describe
their nuclear forces onto higher
readiness
and what that means
is that the command and control system
for russian nuclear weapons
in peacetime normally would not allow
launch orders to go through
but now that it's on higher alert those
orders can go through so the analogy i
would use would be to say it's like
disengaging the safety catch on a gun
it makes it easier to send orders
through to those nuclear weapons
what does putin hope to achieve with
threats of nuclear escalation
what's important to say is that putting
nuclear forces onto higher readiness
isn't a preparation for using them he's
not about to launch missiles at the west
what the purpose is is to say
don't get in my way as i do this
invasion of ukraine because who knows
where it lend up the risks are so high
he's he's manipulating the risk of this
conflict to try and deter the west from
getting involved and of course it is
involved it's been sending weapons arms
anti-tank weapons ammunition to ukraine
and i think that one of putin's
objectives is to say you're playing with
fire stay out of my way or who knows
where it could all end up
how has the west and nato responded so
far
nato has said that putin's
escalation is irresponsible the west has
said that these are reckless actions uh
in fact many experts have said that as
well because of course whenever you put
nuclear forces onto higher readiness
that does carry the risk of nuclear
launches being easier easier to achieve
um but but what the west hasn't done
importantly is respond in kind it hasn't
said it's putting its own nuclear forces
onto higher alert and indeed it doesn't
need to because america britain and
france the three nuclear-armed powers in
the nato alliance all have nuclear-armed
submarines that patrol the oceans around
the world hidden under the sea at all
times in other words weapons that can't
be found weapons that can't be taken out
and so they're always ready and able to
respond and nobody has been putting
their their land-based missiles or their
bombers on high alert because i think
they realize the important thing to do
now is to keep these risks down and not
follow putin's lead
are putin's threats posturing or a real
danger
putin's threats are both posturing and
they're a real danger they're a real
danger because of course um nuclear
weapons are serious things they can
they're weapons that can cause the
annihilation of the entire planet as we
know it and although the risk of of an
accidental or or
unauthorized launch are very low indeed
with nuclear weapons people tend to be
extremely cautious
but i think they're also um actions that
show uh perhaps a sense of weakness a
sense that he's afraid of western
intervention his war in the first few
days has not been as quick or as easy as
he might have imagined and i think he's
very very keen indeed to keep the west
completely out of it so his threats his
his his language his rhetoric all of it
is intended to say stay away stay out of
this don't get in my way and i think all
of that conveys a whiff of fear perhaps
a whiff of vulnerability
what does nato need to do now and how
critical are the next few weeks
this is a very tense moment it's
probably the most tense moment in
european security for a generation
because it's a huge land war right on
the edge of nato's territory and and and
i think everyone appreciates the risks
are incredibly high both sides right now
are feeling out how far the other side
might be willing to go the approach the
west has taken so far is to say these
threats are going to be taken seriously
but we're not going to back down we're
going to keep providing arms we're going
to keep applying heavy heavy sanctions
that are annihilating russia's economy
right now and we're going to keep
supporting the ukrainians in their
resistance against russia but i think
there's also a recognition at the same
time that people have to think about
potential off-ramps people have to think
about potential diplomacy for example
like the meeting between ukrainian and
russian officials that took place on the
border with belarus in the last couple
of days
could putin really start a nuclear war
i don't think there's any reason to
think that vladimir putin wants to start
a nuclear war or that he would be
willing to do so given that his own
country his own regime his own
leadership but his own people would be
killed in a response because that's the
reality of modern nuclear weapons
that what we have is a situation of what
was called mutually assured destruction
if vladimir putin launches nuclear
weapons at the west nato would launch
nuclear weapons at russia and that
relationship creates creates a degree of
stability
a degree of predictability what's
important to remember is that the
deliberate initiation of a nuclear war
isn't the only scenario we ought to be
concerned about in a situation where you
have a a huge conflict in ukraine lots
of nato activity and america and other
countries reinforcing eastern europe
with thousands of new troops warships in
the black sea in close proximity
accidents can happen and those accidents
could in theory spiral into armed
conflict and armed conflict can result
in exchanges of nuclear forces that is
profoundly unlikely and no one should
exaggerate the likelihood of that but
it's because nuclear weapons are so
destructive that nobody should take any
chances and that the two sides need to
exercise all of the lines of
communication they have at their
disposal and make sure that they do
nothing to raise the temperature in a
reckless way which unfortunately is
exactly what the russian side is doing
right now
thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe